tu veux qu'on regarde un truc sur la
main et les villas oui c'est compliqué
parce qu'ils sont là le sait le chanteur
la suisse est ouverte jusqu'au n'est pas
bien oui tu m'aimes dire après on
regarde le café de flore ou la brasserie
lipp les intellectuels parisiens ont
l'habitude de se retrouver dans des
cafés dit littéraire lieu de rencontre
ou d'inspiration
ils font partie des rites propre au
monde de l'édition depuis vingt ans les
éditions fayard et grasse et avaient
établi leur quartier général aux
twickenham
à deux pas de saint germain des prés
aujourd'hui le peuple ferme pour laisser
place à une boutique de prêt-à-porter
la littérature est en deuil grasset
l'orphelinat prononcé la semaine
dernière
l'éloge funèbre de son temple spirituel
c'était le centre de mon monde et voilà
mon monde n'a n'a plus ce centre là
alors on peut bien sûr en chercher un
autre mais ça sera pas facile
pour l'instant disons que je suis en
manque et plus jeune pour prendre mes
messages quand je suis dans paris comme
j'ai toujours pas de téléphone dans ma
voiture lui on renvoyait tout aux
twickenham j'étais sûr d'avoir tout à la
fin de la journée ça c'est vraiment pour
moi dramatique ça a posé un problème
fondamental qui est de savoir s'il vaut
mieux demander de l'argent à son éditeur
dans son bureau dans un endroit où il a
déjà vu cela dit c'est la vie mais ça va
être très très dur de vivre un flic et
bernard henri lévy l'écrivain vedette de
ce bistro a refusé toute interview trop
triste il craignait certainement de
s'effondrer face à la caméra le désarroi
des gens de lettres et relayé par
l'action des étudiants à sciences po
soutenus par leurs aînés ils ont lancé
une pétition afin d'empêcher que les
petits secrets et grandes intrigues de
twickenham ne soit à jamais enfouis sous
les fripes de luxe
bref qu'il soit classé non pas monuments
historiques notion trop poussiéreuse
mais lieu de mémoire celle de la bande à
bhl c'est un endroit qui n'est pas à
protéger en soi mais qui représente
tellement de choses dans l'imaginaire
collectif que ça a vraiment sa mairie
des protégés comme le l'hôtel du nord
qu'ils étaient protégés pour le cinéma
la requête a été déposée au ministère de
la culture lequel nous a signalé non
sans ironie d'ailleurs qu'une grotte de
vingt mille ans venait d'être découverte
près de marseille soit 1000 fois plus
d'années de mémoire que le café préféré
de nos écrivains
voilà le peuple fréquenté par bernard
henri lévy bientôt classé lieu de
mémoire
gérard jugnot à l'oreille florent à toi
de jouer c'est l'info c'est de l'intox
your info unique c'est de l'info ouais
enfin parce que tu dis les mégalos il
est bien capable de faire ça ouais et
wanted vanessa france c'est l'info aussi
bagheera c'est beaucoup moins brillant
que la semaine dernière on t'écoute
philippe s de la peau est ce de la toge
une petite idée
philippe guérin et oui on se dirige tout
droit vers le tirs aux obus est au mieux
de vous voulez ouais c'est et de l'info
au delà et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu